الى هذه الساعه الاخباريه التحليليه نواكب
من خلالها الحدث في تونس هذه الايام
والحدث مشاهدينا هو الانتخابات التشريعيه
الانتخابات البرلمانيه
2022 انتخابات ضغط عليها او طغى عليها
جدال سياسي البعض حتى ذهب بتوصيفه
بالاضطرابات السياسيه هذه الانتخابات ضغط
عليها كذلك ازمه اقتصاديه وسنخصص هذه
الساعه للحديث عن هذه الازمه وعن
تداعياتها ادخل في جوهر الموضوع واستقبل
ضيوفي هناك معنا الدكتور محمد الجويلي
استاذ علم الاجتماع اهلا بك
دكتور عز الدين السعيدان خبير اقتصاديه
اهلا بك ومعنى كذلك السيد خميس وزير
الخارجيه السابق رئيس المجلس التونسي
للعلاقات الدوليه اهلا بك معنا سيد خميس
الموضوع على الحقيقه في العديد من
التفاصيل ولكن اسمحوا لي ان ابدا ب- كيف
ينظر التونسي او ما الذي ينتظر التونسي من
هذه الانتخابات دكتور اعتقد ان التونسي لا
ينتظر شيئا من هذه الانتخابات يعني في اول
مره موقف همم لا اكون مو عادي ولكن موقف
فيه كثير من الضبابيبيات في التعامل مع
شيء مجهول تقريبا لانه كل انتخابات
تطرح بدائل ما كانت تعيد هذه البدائل
الاقتصاديه السياسيه اجتماعيه والناس
يتمسكون بهذه البدائل ويتنافسون على هذه
المبادئ على هذه البدائل ولكن لاول مره
نشعر انه هذه الانتخابات لا بدايه لها
يعني انها انتخابات لا تطرح مشروعا سياسيا
اقتصاديا اجتماعيا تقريبا همم لا يمكن ان
نقر ان هذه الانتخابات لها الطعم اصلا لا
يمكن في اعتقادي ان يكون لها طعم لا طعم
سياسي لا تعمل تنافس بالاساس في غياب
الاحزاب السياسيه اعتقد انه نحن امام
انتخابات من نوع اخر لاول مره حتى قبل
الثوره لاول مره نشعر انه في بات من نوع
جديد وربما الخبره في العلم الاجتماع
السياسي هذه فرصتهم كي يفهموا ما الذي
يحصل الان في تراث ما الذي يحصل في هذه
الانتخابات التي لا رائحه ولا تعمل لها
لانه لا تطرح بدائل لا تطرح التنافس ولا
تطرح تقريبا همم
وحتى رؤيه للمستقبل القريب يعني لا توجد
هذه المسائل لانه لا توجد همم احزاب
سياسيه متنافسه حول هذه الموضوع لا توجد
كما قلت بدائل واضحه هم افراد مترشحون
لهذه الانتخابات كله له بديله وفي العاده
بدال شفت انا همم همم
[تصفيق]
اجراءاتهم الانتخابيه يعني مع الاسف
معناها برامج انت غبيه لا معنى لها مضحكه
في الغالب واا
خلينا نناقش ذلك
تناولها التونسيون وطرحها
همم يعني طرحتها نسبه من التونسيين ولكن
هناك كذلك من يدعم هذا الاجراء هناك من
يتحدث الدكتور عز الدين بانه هذا الاجراء
ياتي همم ضمن خطه استراتيجيه ضمن مسار
الخمس والعشرين من جويل يا همم ضيف يقول
بانه لدور او لا رائحه ولا طعم ولكن هل
لها دور في هذا المسار وان كان الجانب
الاقتصادي يقع على مسار سياسي جد مهم في
تونس وهو في الحقيقه كل مرحله انتخابيه
المفروض تاتي بحلول ومن ضمنها بالنسبه
لتونس الان حلول اقتصاديه انا تونس تمر
باوضاع اقتصاديه وماليه واجتماعيه خالقه
جدا وغير مسبوقه في حقيقه الامر في تاريخ
تونس
فالسؤال ما هو مضمون هذه الانتخابات ما هو
همم الرهان وراء هذه الانتخابات وهل ان
هذه الانتخابات ستمر بتونس نادي المرحله
الاستثنائيه الى مرحله استقرار سياسي
تتمكن فيه تونس من الى الاهتمام وال-
الانكباب الكامل على اوضاع الاقتصاديه
والماليه والاجتماعيه ويبدو ان الجواب له
وما حصل بالامس وربما نعودي لهذا الموضوع
يعني القرار اللي تم اتخاذه من صندوق
النقد الدولي يعني يزيد الوضع التعقيدا
بشكل كبير جدا وبالتالي تساؤلات كبيره
ماذا
ستاتي به هذه الانتخابات وماذا ستضيفه على
الوضع الصعب الذي تمر به تونس
وحضرتك مراقب جيد خبير جيد نجيب له معسي
يعني همم ممتاز في تونس همم والاكيد بانك
ركبت كذلك في السنوات همم السابقات كيف
لهذه المعادله ان تتحقق اقتصاد وسياسه ما
المجال الذي يجب ان يصب غيره هل يجب ان
تكون هناك اسس سياسيه تحقق نجاح اقتصاد او
العكس اللي يج ان يكون مطروح هو اولا لابد
من التذكير ان تونس من البلدان القلائل
اللي تقريبا عندها سنه ونصف بدون برلمان
يعني هذه الانتخابات اذا كان عندها اهميه
بكره انه على الاقل على المستوى الشكل
سيكون هناك تكون هناك مؤسسه تسمى برلمان
ولا يمكن ان نصادق على اتفاقيه اقتصاديه
او همم تكون الحكومه مصداقيه في طاعتها مع
الخارج بدون مؤسسه برلمانيه لكن مع الاسف
هذا كما جاء في كلام همم صديقين من قبل
يعني هذا هذا المصاري يعني مع الاسف من
الاصل لم يكن لم يكن الراي العام والاهل
السياسه من الحوار حول امهات القضايا التي
تطرح على تونس اليوم وبالتالي هي كما قال
همم الاستاذ جويلي يعني انتخابات بدون
طعام بدون هدف ليس هناك احزاب سياسيه ولا
يمكن تحدث عن انتخابات وجدل سياسي بدون
حضور انتخابات لكن همم على الاقل يعني حتى
انه يكون متفائلين انو هذه الانتخابات من
المفروض ان تضع حد على الاقل فتره معينه
للفتره الاستثنائيه يعني لان احنا نعيشه
في فتره استثنائيه بدون مؤسسات اليوم بكره
سيئه
تسمى البرلمان
يعني تكون عندها ما يمكن ما همم المصداقيه
حتى تقدم الحلول
البرامج السياسيه
على مستوى حضور المراه يعني في هذا في هذا
البرنامج ليه معناها مصداقيه هذه البرلمان
من الاصل يعني هي منقوصه همم نتمنى نتمنى
ان تمر العمليه انتخابيه يا سلام حتى احنا
فقط الحالات غدا سنواكب هذه العمليه
الانتخابيه اليوم سنخصص هذه الساعه
لمناقشه التطورات الاقتصاديه بالاساس
والاجتماعيه كذلك في تونس بما انه نزلنا
في حضور الصمت الانتخابات ولكن غدا سنفصل
همم اجراءات هذه الانتخابات وتدعيات
السياسيه ولكن ساعود معك في نقطه سيد خميس
اتيت على ذكر اهميه الرؤيا
الدوليه لهذه الانتخامات فيماتهم والله
لما اذا كان نحب نحلل يعني كيفيه كيف ينظر
لان العالم بخصوص الانتخابات وردود الفعل
يعني
البرلمان الاوروبي قرر عدم حضور هذه
البرلمان وعدم وقتها همم
وبالتالي همم اول مره 2011 همم معناها
المراقبين الاجانب لا يحضرون والمراقبين
ان هذا مش داخل التونسي هذا يعطي مصداقيه
بالاضافه الى المراقبين الداخليين معناه
توينسه في في ما بين يعني انه يكون في
حضور اجنبي يعطي مصداقيه خاصه لدى الاطراف
الدوليه اللي احنا محتاجينها كما قال
الاستاذ عز الدين في تعاملنا معها لحتى
نحاول نجد طرق للخروج من الازمه
الاقتصاديه لاحلى هذه المصداقيه التي
يتحدث عنها السيد خميس
كافيه للتعامل مع الجهاد الماليه الدوليه
كندوق النقد الدولي او ان هناك اسس كان
يجب على الحكومه ان همم
تضمنها او ان توفرها على الاقل همم
لمحاوله ايجاد حلول لانه همم اليوم
التصريحات او الواقع يقول بان صندوق النقد
الدولي اجل وحضرتك اعلم بانك همم تطرح
فكره فرس او رفض عفوا رفص همم ملف تونس
لماذا تحدث عن رفض هذا الملف وتاجيله اجعل
خير مسمى اول شيء لو تسمح لما نقرا
الدستور الجديد للبلاد التونسيه ونشوف ما
هي صلاحيات
البرلمان الجديد ترى انها ضعيفه جدا وهذا
يعني يبين لماذا هذه الانتخابات ليس لها
رهان وليس لها مضمون وان حتى الاطراف
الاجنبيه وشركائنا معناها مش ممكن
يتعاملوا مع برلمان ما عندوش صلاحيات
فالكل يفهم انه السلطات ستبقى متركزه لدى
السيد رئيس جمهوريه فقط وهذا لا يعطي
مصداقيه للحياه السياسيه في تونس وليه
السلطات التونسيه ككل وبالتالي حتى مع
صندوق النقد الدولي اعتقد انه هذه
الانتخابات لن تغيره اي شيء وستبقى النظره
الى التونسي نفس النظره والخوف كل الخوف
مثل ما قلنا انه هذه المرحله بتعطينا حلول
جديده مش مش تسمع ربما الى العلاقات
على مستوى الثنائي على مستوى المؤسسه
الماليه الدوليه انها تتحسن بمفعول هذه
الانتخابات من تونس تكون فعلا خرجت من وضع
استثنائي الى وضع سياسي طبيعي مستقر يسمح
بالقيام بالاصلاحات التي تاخرت بشكل كبير
والتي تسببت في هذا الوضع الخطير الذين
نمر به الان
منذ فتره بعنوان العقد الاجتماعي هل هذه
الانتخابات يمكن ان تاتي في اطار او تؤسس
لشيء يخدم هذا العقد الاجتماعي تقول بانه
هذا العقد الاجتماعي مهم ويجب ان يعاد او
ان يتجدد من فتره الى اخرى لنكون امام
مجتمع مكون من عناصر متوازنه سياسيه
اجتماعيا اقتصاديا فهل هذه الانتخابات
يمكن ان تاتيها في هذا الاطار للدفع بهذا
المسار
الان في مرحله فيها نوع من الخيرام العقد
الاجتماعي لانه عقد الاجتماعي انتهى يوم
25 جويليه يوم 25 جويه تغيرت اوضاع
جديده
ولكن اعود الى السيد خميس في نفس هذا
الاطار في الواقعه لان مسار 25 جويليه
يتحدث على خطه فحضرتك هل تعتقد بانه هذه
الانتخابات يمكن ان تؤسس لشيء فعلي غير
انه كما تحدث السيد عز الدين همم ليس هناك
دور مهم لهذا البرلمان ولكن هناك خطه هناك
استراتيجيه تحدث عنها رئيس قيس سعيد خطوه
خطوه يمكن ان نعمل على شيء فعلي يؤسس
لمجتمع همم سليم تعتقد سيد خميس
تصل الى مداها لابد ان يقتنع بها
التونسيون وهذا التونسي كيف
تكون ردد همم
لكن اهم نقدر ان الازمه الاقتصاديه اللي
احنا عايشينها لابد ان يقتنع بها سوره
يونس لان تونس معناها متفتحه الخارج ولابد
ان
المناهل الخارج وشركائنا ساعدونا لمده عشر
سنوات لارساء ديمقراطيه ناشئه في تونس
واخيرا الولايات المتحده نفسها اكدت على
هذا لابد انها تكون هذه الانتخابات مرحله
اخلى اضافيه في ترسيخ المسار الديمقراطي
هذا
يظهر لنا بعد هذه الانتخابات
المراحل التي ادت الى هذه الانتخابات لا
تدل انه كانت مرحله فيها همم توافق داخلي
فما حوار بين مختلف همم
المجتمع يعني صحيح الى الصندوق النقد
الدولي والموضوع الاساسي همم لماذا لم
تنجح الحكومه تونسيه في همم
القيام بما يلزم لاقناع صندوق النقد
الدولي بما تقدمت به من طلب للقرض هو خلاف
اللي ما يقال يعني داخل صندوق النقد
الدولي ليس هناك تصويت
ولايه المتحده
الذي يحصل فعلا وان الصندوق النقد الدولي
قبل ايام من الاجتماع يحاول التاكد من ان
البرنامج
ليس بالبنك العادي صندوق النقد الدولي جزء
منظومه الامم المتحده والدوره الاساسي هو
في مساعده الدول التي تمر بصعوبات
اقتصاديه صعبه مع العلم انه يعتبر الملف
الاخير بمعنى اي دوله ما يقراها الصندوق
النقد الدولي ما فيش حتى الطرف يقرضها
وبالتالي الصندوق الدولي يريد التاكد انه
البرنامج عنده ما يكفي من الحدود للنجاح
كيف ذلك يعني الى جانب تمويل صندوق النقد
الدولي لابد ان يكون هناك اط اخرى على
مستوى ثنائي او مستوى مؤسسات ماليه دوليه
بتشارك في نفس المشروع بس نجح نفس المشروع
والوضح ان الصوره التونسي لم تنجح في هذا
الجانب ولم تتمكن من تعبئه الموارد
الكافيه وحتى الوعود الكافيه لتوفير هذه
المواد هذا اهم سبب هذا فقط
مهم جدا وانه يعني العمليه الكامله مع
صندوق النقد الدولي منذ بدايه المحادثات
التقنيه الى التوصل الى اتفاق نهائي وصرف
القسم الاول المفروض تتطلب ثلاثه اشهر في
الوضع بتاع تونس المحادثات التقنيه فقط
تطلب من 18 شهر سنه ونصف ثم حتى بعد
محادثه التقنيه وبعد الحصول على اتفاق
المبدئي هناك على الاقل شهرين يعني منذ 15
ديسمبر السبب واضح جدا هناك مش كل مصداقيه
للبلاد التونسيه في مخصص معاملاتها مع
صندوق النقدي والجهات المالحه لانه كان
عندنا في 2013 ولما ينجح ثم برنامج ثاني
2016 ولا ينشح ايضا يعني تونس تتقدم
ببرنامج الاصلاحات ولكنها لا تلتزم بذلك
البرنامج فبالتالي ما حصل الان وان صندوق
النقد الدولي طلب ان يعني يطلع على مشروع
قانون الماليه 23 قبل صدوره للتاكد من انه
ما فيش تضارب وتناقض ما بينه وما بين
المشروع بتاع الاصلاحات اللي تقدمت به
سلطه التونسيه
همم هذا القانون المفروض يكون جاهز هذه
المرحله العاشره
جدا
غير متناغم مع همم البرنامج الاصلاحات
وكان صندوق النقد الدولي يطلب ان يكون
موقعه من طرف السيده رئيس الجمهوريه علم
انه انه اصوله طاقه الان يعني كلها متمركز
في يد الرئيس الجمهوريه
لا التوقيع فكل هذه الظروف ادت الى
جانب انه كان هناك لمده طويله خطاب متناقض
ومتباين بشكل كبير يعني رئيس الجمهوريه في
واد والحكومه رئيس الجمهوريه التي تفاوضت
مع صندوق النقد والفئه الثاني والمجتمع
المدني وخاصه الاتحاد العام تونس الشغل
رافض تماما لهذا المسار بتاع الاصلاحات
بما فيه خاصه التوفيق في بعض المؤسسات
العموميه واصلاح منظومه الدعم فهذا الكل
جعل الاطراف امامنا تشك في قدره السلطه
التونسيه على القيام الفعلي بالاصلاحات
الضروريه
لهذا التناقص كما وصفته بين تصريحات
الرئيس وتصريحات الحكومه معك بعد قليل
ولكن اعود فقط الى ضيفه دكتور جويلي كنا
تحدث عن العقد الاجتماعي في ربط مع كل ما
يحدث من تفاصيله هذه الازمه سواء على همم
المستوى السياسي لذلك على المستوى
الاقتصادي ما الذي فقدناه في تونس ما الذي
فلت منا حتى يقول التونسيون باننا في
مرحله حرجه للغايه هو نوع من العقد
الاجتماعي الذي يضم الدوله مؤسسات الدوله
منظمه الوطنيه الاحزاب السياسيه كل القوه
الحيه في البلاد المتفقه حول مشروع
مجتمعين ولو فيه اختلافات ايضا شركائنا
الخارجين بطريقه باخرى من هذا العقد
الاجتماعي وبالتالي منذ 25 جويليه انتهى
في اعتقاد العقد الاجتماعي الذي كان يضم
كل التونسيين وجدنا انفسنا امام وضعيه
جديده تماما
تتحدث عنه في مقاله قلت في ما قبل قبل
2000 واحد عشره كان هناك كانت هناك تركيبه
سياسيه همم قادره ان تبني لمستقبل ولكن من
2011 وحتى اليوم كان هناك
الحكومات بدليل انه في نوع من التوافق
بطريقه او باخرى يعني كنا متفقين على انه
تم عقد اجتماعي الكلمه الفصل او العنوان
الابرز لهذه العقد الاجتماعي هو تركيز ما
يمكن اسبيه بالانتقال الديمقراطي يعني
بالانتخابات بالبرلمان بقوه البرلمان بقوه
المؤسسات بدعم المجتمع المدني بدعم
الديمقراطيه الى غير ذلك وصلنا في هذه
العقد بشكل اخر مغاير لما قبل 20 11 في كل
الاحيان او في كل ال- همم اي طريقه هناك
عقد اجتماعي هناك همم فاعلين متفقين او
متعاقدين بطريقه
المنظمات الوطنيه الان في خلاف كبير مع
رئاسه الجمهوريه يعني ولينا يعني
بسدد الباحث عن شيء جديد لا يعني نحن في
مرحله الانتقاليه مهمه جدا وخطيره في نفس
الوقت لم نستطيع انه ان نرجع شئنا
العلامات الاساسيه التي كنا نتحرك من
خلالها ولذلك هذا سيؤثر اولا على القرار
اقتصادي واساسا سيؤثر على المساله
الانسانيه
بان مسار التقليدي هو المسار الصحيح ان
يكون هناك برلمان مسحوب
للمهام او الدور الذي اعتدنا به
ربما يقول بعض بان هذه فكره او طرح جديد
هل يمكن ان نتعود ان همم نحاول ان نجد
ايجابيات كذلك في مثل هكذا منهج لكن
التغيير يمكن ان العقد الاجتماعي هو الذي
يقود عمليه التغيير التغيير السياسي بشكل
عام ما هي المؤسسات البارزه ما هي ما هي
ما هو الخيار الاقتصادي الجديد ما هو ما
يسمى بمنوال التنميه الجديد الى غير ذلك
لكن هذه المره كان القرار قرار تقريبا
فردي ومتواصل في هذه الطريقه بحيث في شخص
واحد هو الذي يقرر بديلا عن الاخرين دون
توافق دون محاولات دون نقاش ولذلك دائما
هناك دعوه لحوار وطني مقصود بالحواره مش
فقط مساله حوار هي مساله الاتفاق حول عقد
اجتماع جديد يشترك حوله الجميع لبناء تونس
المستقبل هذا غير موجود الان ولذلك سيؤثر
بطريقه باخرى حول الانتخابات ماذا نريد من
البرلمان هذا لهذا الاساس الان السؤال
الاساسي ماذا نريد الى البركه انا اعتقد
انه هذه الانتخابات ستعلن نهايه البرلمان
نهايه مؤسسه بارزه في تونس عشنا يعني منها
في واحد قرش الى 2019 تقريبا
تقريبا برلمان قوي فاعل ربما همم كان
برلمان اكثر قوه مما كنا ننتظر اه يعني هو
في يده تقريبا
همم مع التهميش للحكومه بدرجه اقل وخاصه
لرئاسه الجمهوريه ولكن نعتقد ان هذه المره
سيتم اعلان نهايه البرلمان لانه كل عمليه
انتخابيه
او حتى العربي اللي كان يشاهد جلسات
البرلمان سيقول لك طيب كان لكم برلمان
وكان هذا البرلمان بشكل بتدور بالاهميه
التي تروجون او تريدون تكريسهم همم لم
يفيد بشيء
اوكي شوف
يمكن تحسين اداء البرلمان يمكن متابعه
البرلمان وضبط بعض المسائل هذا ممكن جدا
لكن ان نضع البرلمان في هذه الوضعيه الان
في وضعيه انه تقريبا لا دور له والدليل
على ذلك القانون الانتخابي الدليل على ذلك
اقصاء الاحزاب السياسيه
الحملات الانتخابيه بطريقه كبيره جدا
السياسيه
ممكن لكن لكن اي شكل جديد لابد له من
ضمانات له ولو بدي لهم بدهوشه بداغوجيه
سياسيه يعني انت عندك رؤيه جديده للبرلمان
اوكي متفق معك عندك رؤيه جديده مش
بالضروره نكونوا في الرؤيه القديمه اوكي
لكن لابد من بيداغوجيا سياسيه برجيبه
والسيد الوزير استاذ زين يعرفوا منيح اي
قرار يريد ان ان ينقله للناس في بيداغوجيا
كامله في بداويه وتحرير كامل
مع سيد الشناوي نستعلم اكثر بين قبل
واليوم هل نفتقد اليوم الى هوشه وانقل
دائما عن ضيف هو يقول هذه المرحله نفتقد
لي بداخرجي حقيقيه لفكر حقيقي لمنطق حقيقي
همم بين الامس واليوم همم هل هذا دقيق
يمكن القول ذلك فعلا احنا اولا ساعه
الديمقراطيه هذا ما صار لا يمكن ان نقيم
في عشر سنوات يعني احنا التجارب المماثله
في اوروبا شرقيه ورغم انه اوروبا الشرقيه
فما قيت قادره ما هو الاتحاد الاوروبي
ساعدهم مش يوليوود هو الديمقراطيه احنا
همم لمده عشر سنوات كنا لوحده لعنا لا
قاطره اقتصاديه اسمها اتحاد الاوروبي ولا
عنا قاتره ومظله امنيه اسمها الحلف
الاطلسي احنا كنا لوحدنا نتصارع في ما
بيننا ولكن نبني ديمقراطيه هذه
الديمقراطيه لم تصل الى مداه ما زال في
بدايتها
نقاس كبيره لالما المفروض انه نعم حتى
نزيح تلك النقاص وندفع لتستكمال للمصاري
الديمقراطي ما حدث يوم 25 لانه اوقفنا هذا
وقلنا لا هذا كل ما تم هذا همم
مقارنه جديده همم المقارنه الجديده كما
تفضل استاذ هي مقاربه تاتي حصيله لحوار
بين مختلف مكونات المجتمع هذا الحوار لم
يتم لم يحصل لم يحصل وبالتالي وبالتالي
همم معناها حتى حتى انه راي العام والشعب
يدافع على هذه المقاربه لابد ان يقتنع بها
وكيف يقتنع بها لما يشارك في هذه الحوار
ويعبر الراي ويقول هذا مع هذا هو ضد هذا
لكن هذا لم يحصل لم يكن هناك اي حوار يعني
اعود لنفس النقطه كانت في السابق هناك
حوارات وطنيه فتحت المجال لمحاوله ايجاد
حلول ولك فنهايه كنا امام تسويات داخليه
داخل اما الاتحاد او النقابات او المؤسسات
السياسيه
عادي جدا السياسيه
وهذه الديمقراطيه العريقه اللي هي عندها
مشاكل الان في اوروبا وفي غيرها التمثيليه
لا هذه الديمقراطيه عندها اليات وعندها
الاحزاب السياسيه مثلا هي اليه اساسيه في
اي عمل ديمقراطي الحوار والجدل بكل حريه
حول المسائل الجوهري اللي تم المجتمع هذا
موضوع مهم جدا في ايديمقراطيه لا يمكن ان
نسقط يعني ديمقراطيه حسب مفهوم ده همم انا
حتى لو كنت انا احسن واا المع شخص لا يمكن
ان اي شخص هذا هذا النتائج
لمجتمع المجتمع التونسي كان جاهز في
العديد من المراحل وتم تحقيق حتى نقول لك
انا لان عيشنا تم تحقيق خطوات مهمه جدا في
هذا الايطالي
عند هذه الخطوات الايجابيه خلينا او خليني
انا الاقل اكون في مكان شخص الداعم لهذا
المسار بما انكم
براون بانوا هذا المسار يحمل انتقادات او
على الاقل همم هناك نقص ولكن خلينا نشوف
الحلول دكتور عز الدين طيب اليوم نحن امام
رفض تاجيل لملف تونس همم مع صندوق النقد
الدولي وهذا واقع نحن كذلك امام سياسه
لرئيس وكانه اجل او على الاقل همم رفض
سياسه التقشف همم سياسه رفع جزء للدعم عن
المواد الاساسيه ورفع كل للدعم على
المحروقات والى اخره من البنود التي همم
طرحت في فتره من فتره طيب ما الحل ولكن
هناك رفض وليس هناك تقديم حلول ليس هناك
اي رؤيه
وهذا هو الاشكال
انا سالت حظر اقتصادي
التحدي
الوضع كان حار جدا قبل رفض ملف تونس امام
صندوق النقد الدولي والان زاد تعقيدا اذا
شوفوا ما الذي يمكن ان يحصل في سنه 23 في
غياب تمويل من صندوق النقد الدولي
والتمويل الاخرى كانت ربما تاتي بفضل
بوافق صندوق النقد
الوضع سيكون اكثر حرج بدون شكل لانه الان
مخزون البلاد التونسيه من العمله الاجنبيه
تراجع بشكل كبير بين صق مرتفع جدا يعني
منذ اشهر قليله كنا في مستواه 138 يوم من
التوريد ليوم نزلنا الى 94 يوم فقط مع
العلم ان التسعين يوم يعتبر الخط الاحمر
لانه توريد الدواء والغذاء والمحروقات
يتطلب ماء تقريبا 90 يوم من التوريد فهذا
يعني انه تونس وكانها تقول للدائنين راه
سيكون هناك تعثر في تسديد الدين الاجنبي
الرقم الثاني المهم جدا وهو معروف وهو انه
خدمه الدين او مستحقات الدين الاجنبي
للسنه القادمه سنه 23 سيكون حوالي 14
مليار دينار او ما يساوي مرتين ونصف خدمه
الدين الاجنبي في سنه 22
فبمثل هذه الارقام وعلما انه اكبر تحدي في
تونس الان هو مستوى الخارجي مستوى الدين
هو هذا اكبر تحدي بدون اي شكل فالوضع
سيكون صعب وصعب جدا كيف سنواجه لهذه
الاوضاع ليس هناك اي رؤيه الى حد الان
وليس هناك بديل لا من طرف رئاسه جمهوريه
ولان الحكومه قد بديل وبرنامج ولان
المجتمع المدني نفسه والاتحاد العام تونسي
شغل بالاساس قدم ايضا بديل نرى رفضا من
هنا
وهناك ولكن ليس همم ليس هناك حوار يعطينا
فكره ويمكن فعله هل ان التقشف هو الحل او
عدم التقشف وانا ارى التقشف هو من اخطر
السياسات لانه يعمق الازمات ما فيش حتى
شيء اما الحل لا يمكن الان الا ان يكون
التونسي بدون اي شكل به موافق صندوق او
بدون ذلك
احنا في سنه 2010
ميزانيه الدوله كانت 18 مليار دينار ومن
هالربع كان يخصص للاستثمار العمومي اليوم
لسنه 22 وصلنا الى 61 مليار دينار اكبر
اكثر من ثلاث مرات بينما الاستثمار
العمومي لا يمثل الا تقريبا 3% فقط هذه
الهجريه الدوله تخلت تماما عن دورها في
الاستثمار العمومي وبالتالي للاستثمار
الخاص يصبح غير ممكن واستقدام الاستثمار
الاجنبي المباشر يسمح غير ممكن ايضا هنا
الاشكال الكبير لابد من اعاده النظر في
نمط انفاق الدوله
اصبحت تنفق الكثير بالنسبه
لنمو الاقتصادي المحققه لمده 12 سنه كانت
صفر فاصل 58 بينما نفقه الدوله ترتفع اكثر
من 12% سنويا وهنا فقط عامه وليست نفقات
استثمار من شانها تخلق الثروه وتمكن
الدوله التونسيه من تسديد ديونها الطبيعيه
التعثر في تسديد الدين
لا محاله واذا وصلنا الى هذا فهذا يعني ان
تون ستدخل فيما يسبب دوامه اعاده جدوله
الدين الخارجي والمرور امام ما يسمى بنادي
باريس
وهذا سينار الممكن ليس الاسوء لكن الممكن
في سنه 23 طبعا بهذه الظروف وخاصه بعد هذا
الرفض لملف تونس من طرف صندوق النقد ولكن
الدكتور جويلي راهم كل هذا ورغم هذه
الاعداد هذه الارقام وهذه النساء وحتى
تصريحات انه خبط تونسيه اليوم نرى التونسي
ليس في هذه الانتخابات نحن السنهبعه غدا
مستوى الاقبال عليها ولكن منذ 25
همم وحتى بعده بمراحل تبعنا بان التونسي
كان همم داعم او على الاقل
همم يرى املا يرى بقعه ضوء في هذه
الاجراءات كيف يفسر ذلك
كل انتخابات لها عنوان
انتخابات 2011 لها عنوانها 2014
سياسيه بشكل عام تتنافس حول هذا العنوان
كل واحد يريد ان ياخذ قصه من هذا العنوان
عنوان العامريه الانتخابيه في الوحدات هو
الهويه بشكل عام تاريخ النظاري الى غير
ذلك 2014 هو استرجاع هيبه الدوله
2014 2019 هو اعاده ترتيب العلاقه بين
المواطن والدوله بما يسمى الثقه
بالمعنى السياسي لوما اختلاف عناوين
الكبرى
مخاوي في الان هو انه هذه الانتخابات
البرلمانيه بلا عنوان بلا عنوان لانه همم
يعني حتى بعض التعليقات همم همم هناك امل
بامكانيه يعني ثلاثه تكون متفاجئين بانه
يمكن ان يكون هناك امل ولكن هناك في امل
السيد وزير صحيح لانه نحن كذلك نعيش تجارب
وحضرتك منذ قليل قلت بانه الديمقراطيه
تدرس ونحن تلامذه هذه المرحله همم خليني
نبدا همم
بدايه من 25 دقيقه ما قبل 25 جويليه مش
انه ما قبل 25 جويليه هو هو النموذج
الاسلم يمكن لاي قوه سياسيه في هذه الحاله
رئيس الجمهوريه ان ياتي من وائل جديد
برؤيه جديده اوكي عادي يعني انا انسان ما
هوش متسب يعني لا بدنه في تغيير في
ديناميكيه لعمليه الانتقال الديمقراطي
ولكن هذا المشكل اللي وين المشكله اللي هو
انه البديل الذي قدمته او الذي قدم الان
بديل غير واضح هذا المشكله احنا يا ريت يا
ريت انه احنا ناخذه تجربه جديده ياريت انه
نتعلموا من التجربه السابقه وشوفوا ما هي
همم نقاط قوتها ما هي نقاط سلبي نقاط
سلبيه فيها ونبني على نموذج جديد وعلى
بديل جديد نحن مع هذا ولكن
هل تعتمد في هكذا خلاصه على الوضع
الاقتصادي او ان لك قراءات او مقابل
اذا هو لم يقدر هذا النموذج البديل بين
ظفرين لم يقدر ان يتجاوز الاشكال
الاقتصادي هل له رؤيه للمستقبل هل له رؤيه
لقضايا كبرى في التعليم في الاصلاحات
الكبرى في الاصلاحات التعقي في الاصلاح
الجبائي يعني مش شيء على الاقل
واحنا متفقين يكونوا متفقين البلدنا مؤكد
ولكن يا ريت تمشي ممكن يعني اتسب به ولو
شيء معين نقول ممكن هذه ممكن ينق
هذا غير موجود الان على الاقل في المرحله
ثم تغييب اعلامي كبير يعني مفيش الحكومه
بشكل عام لا تتكلم لا تتكلم مش نعرفه مش
نعرف لانه دائما نبحث عن بدائل وجيد
البدائل ودي اني بقيه المجتمعات
وديمقرايتات هي في قدرتها على ارثاء بدائل
جديده و يصير فيه نقاش وتصير فيه يعني
توافق او او ترتيبات مهما كان الامر لكن
فيه نقاش ف- اا لا نرى بديلا واضحا يعني
فيه بدائل صامطه ان كانت هناك بدائل ولكن
في الاغلبيه صامته لا تتكلم همم بدون جاء
بدون
الغموض دائما مخيف اللي يخلينا يا ريت ان
يكون في شيء ملموس
يعني بانه همم هذا غلط
احنا نعيش في وضع داخلي معقد واقتصاد ازمه
اقتصاديه غير مسبوقه
ومعناها ديمقراطيه كما قلتله ولكن نحن
نعيش في وضع دولي واقليمي متحرك وبالتالي
همم اذا كان مع الناس قراءه لوضعنا الداخل
وكيف نخرج بيفاق وطني يعني معقول انه فمن
الحكومه اللي هي عينها رئيس الجمهوريه
اللي هي جزء من الحاله الاستثنائيه بتاع
25 عندها سياسه ورئيس الجمهوريه عنده سنه
ثانيه همم في حين هو عينها وهو وهي مسؤوله
امامه ما هذه الصوره اللي نعطيها للعالم
نعطيه صوره انه احنا مش يعني سحب هذا او
سحب او همم معناها قضيه همم الصندوق ال-
همم
يعني عدم ادراج تونس
يوم 19 من شهر هذا هذا معناه يعكس معناها
مشكله تحكم في تونس لانه غير صوره تونس
تونس هذا البلد اللي كانت عنده قدرات على
مستوى الموارد البشريه وكان معناه مثال في
العالم العربي وفي حتى في العالم سيف
العامه اليوم غير قادرين بس قدموا ملف
للنقد الدولي والنسحبوه ولا نطلب ارجاعه
يعني
تقديم المعلومات
يمكن ان يقول لك بعضهم بانه لا يمكن ان
تحملها تونس وحدها اليوم همم يتحدث
الدكتور همم عبد العزيز على انه عز الدين
عفوا على انه همم هناك همم كذلك نقطه اخرى
لم تتمكن الحكومه من همم تنفيذها وهي
محاوله الحشد حشد اموال اليوم ولكن العالم
يشهد كذلك الوزير
كون هنا مسئوليه سنتين احنا سنتين نتحاور
مع الصندوق النقد الدولي ونحن عنا سنتين
ونقول نحن في حاجه الى هذا القرن وكانت
طموحا وناخذ اربعه مليارات مليارات دولار
من صندوق
قرر مليار وتعليق مليون يعني مسؤوليه
الحكومه لمده سنتين او على الاقل لمده
تذوب عواصم العالم وتقنع شركائنا بضروره
مستجد تونسي
الموضوع سيبقى للمتابعه همم انتهى الوقت
بسرعه هذا همم شكرا لكم جزيل الشكر همم
الدكتور محمد جويلي استاذ علم الاجتماع
شكرا